Speaker 1: It's great to welcome to the program
today.
Democratic Congressman Jamie Raskin, who represents
Maryland's eighth Congressional District,
was the lead House manager in the second impeachment
trial of former President Donald Trump.
Congressman, it's so great to have you on.
Speaker 5: I'm delighted to be with you, David.
Thank you for having me.
Speaker 1: So, okay, to start with, we're
going to have starting with in primetime on
June 9th, these public hearings related to
the January six committee.
And there are sort of two opposing forces
here.
There's one side, yourself included, who have
been saying what's going to be revealed during
those hearings is going to be mind blowing.
That's my term, not necessarily a term that
you have used.
The other side is this feeling that nothing's
really going to happen.
Nobody's ultimately going to be held accountable
for what happened.
What can you say to those in my audience who
are in that latter group who are concerned
about lack of accountability?
Speaker 5: Well, this is all part of the process
of making the events of January six visible,
comprehensible to people and making them the
basis of real accountability.
Now, some of that accountability is legal
accountability, and that's really within the
realm of the Department of Justice, which
has brought more than 800 prosecutions in
the most sweeping investigation in the history
of the DOJ.
Obviously, we're all on the edge of our seats
to see if they're going to work their way
all the way up to the top, or whether Trump,
as a kind of mob boss, is able to insulate
himself with several layers of buffer between
him and the criminal actions and the legal
consequences of those actions.
But I do think that the investigation is proceeding
apace and they're working their way up the
way that a lot of organized crime investigations
work their way up the ladder.
But then there's there's public and political
accountability.
And that's really what the January 6th Select
Committee is all about.
I mean, under House Resolution 503, our job
is to report to Congress and to the American
people about what happened on January 6th
and what were the causes behind it, and then
to make recommendations about how to fortify
our institutions going forward.
Speaker 1: Do you expect some of your colleagues
in the House may have legal liability?
Speaker 5: Well.
You know, first of all, again, that's not
really our role.
In other words, understood.
We are now we're turning over evidence of
people who are in of Congress because they
refuse to participate.
For example, Dan Scavino and Peter Navarro,
you know, they never gave a single documents
to the committee.
They never spent one minute testifying.
They just blew us off.
Mark Meadows is kind of one foot in and one
foot out.
Doing the hokey pokey gave us some stuff and
then Trump got mad, withdrew, you know, Steve
Bannon's stuff.
We've turned all of that information over
to the Department of Justice.
We voted to hold them in contempt, and now
it's up to the executive branch and the DOJ
to enforce that.
In terms of evidence of other crimes, we are
in the process of laying them out there.
And, you know, in the John Eastman litigation,
when Judge Carter was dealing with Eastman's
claim that he was somehow covered by attorney
client privilege, the judge asked the question,
well, was there an attorney client privilege?
Was it waived?
And what did it.
Does it even apply if it existed because of
the crime fraud exception?
And we said there was no attorney client privilege.
If there was, it was waived.
And, you know, in any event, it doesn't apply
because all of these crimes were committed
and we set them forth.
And Judge Carter basically adopted what we
had to say.
So we've not been shy about setting forth
statutory offenses.
But yet, as much as we all would like to see
Donald Trump and others in his inner echelon
held legally accountable, far more important
is whether or not we can solidify our democratic
institutions and keep the engines of democracy
turning.
I mean, that's just so much more important
than, you know, how Donald Trump spends the
remaining years of his life, whether it's
behind bars or somewhere else.
I care a lot more about whether or not we
are going to be able to bequeath the democracy,
a working, functional democracy to our children
and our grandchildren, because the autocrats,
the dictators, the despots are on the march
all over the world.
And from Moscow to Mar a Lago, they're working
to undermine democratic process and to drain
life from our institutions.
And we've got to make sure we've got something
to give our kids.
Speaker 1: Yeah, to that end, I mean, it seems
very clear that at least to some degree, some
of the people who are trying to avoid coming
before your committee are trying to run out
the clock, knowing that if Republicans take
the House in November and are sworn in in
January, this committee is is essentially
over.
Is your plan to be done long before that in
order to prevent an interruption before you're
done with your work as a result of
the election?
Speaker 5: You're able to have our hearings
begin tonight.
There will be six hearings at least that take
place in the month of June.
There will be perhaps another hearing or two
in the future to deliver the recommendations
of the committee.
And there will be a report, and we're hoping
to have all of that done early in the fall.
You know, it's not just our committee that
ends with this Congress.
Everything ends with this Congress because
House of Representatives, unlike the Senate,
is a new a newly constituted body every two
years.
You know, we come to the end of the Congress
and then there's a new Congress that forms
the Senate because of the overlapping nature
of their terms, is a continuing body.
They only lose one third of their members
or one third of their members are up for reelection.
Whereas our entire body is up for reelection
and we adopt new rules and outs and so on.
So it's not any kind of strategic political
calculus.
It's just that we've got to get this done
before this session of Congress ends.
Speaker 1: Okay.
When it comes to gun safety, there have been
some of your colleagues who have said something
feels different this time.
We've seen a couple of Republicans, including
Adam Kinzinger and Congressman Jacobs, who
have said, I actually have a new position
when it comes to either an assault weapons
ban or a AR 15.
There's something that that might be a little
bit different this time.
But we've seen this cycle for a long time,
which is there's a mass shooting.
Everybody says we must do something.
Republicans come in and say, oh, yeah, sure.
But that can include actually dealing with
gun safety.
And then there's no major shooting in the
news for a couple of weeks and nothing happens
and it's rinse repeat for year after year
after year.
Is your genuine opinion that this is going
to be that same cycle or that maybe something
will be different this time?
Speaker 5: Well, you know, my my colleagues
senior to me believe it is going to be the
exact same thing it's been before, because
the NRA exerts such a stranglehold over the
GOP and in the final analysis, they will refuse
to move.
On the other hand, you know, I'm of the mind
that the Republicans think that they are in
a place where they can actually seize control
of the House and the Senate and they can win
these elections.
You know, they've obviously been vilifying
and demonizing Joe Biden, and yet they're
starting to realize that the public is overwhelmingly
against them on all the big issues.
I mean, you know, they are the dog.
They caught the car when it comes to destroying
Rove versus Wade and the constitutional right
to privacy.
So that creates explosive political conditions
where the women of America can turn en masse
against the GOP and what they've done to destroy
women's reproductive freedom.
Similarly, the the gun violence is so out
of control and so dangerous and frightening
to people that there could be they could experience
this terrible break with young people in America
who just say enough is enough.
And the young people who really rocked American
politics in Parkland, Florida, with the March
for Our Lives are organizing another march.
And people are saying that hundreds of thousands
or maybe even a million people could come
to Washington.
So I think that the GOP may have the sense
that their big chance to do what they really
care about most, which is taking power, could
all be squandered because of the recklessness
of their policies.
And so that would argue that they might try
to do something so that they're not so clearly
the party that is tagged with all these massacres.
One of my constituents wrote me the other
day with the idea that the massacres should
be named after the Republican members of Congress
and the senators whose districts and states
they represent.
When those are the members who are doing nothing
to get us a universal, violent criminal background
check, doing nothing to close the, you know,
the gun show loophole, the Internet loophole,
the private sale loophole, doing nothing to
take weapons of war out of the hands of 18
year olds and, you know, essentially reproduce
the slaughter, which puts America into a class
completely of its own.
I mean, you know, we're suffering gun casualties
20 times, 25, 50 times higher than other industrialized
countries.
And it's all because.
Speaker 1: You know, on that note, many of
my liberal friends who are for all sorts of
different gun safety regulations, which I
know you support and which I support, also
are of the mindset that they don't love the
idea of only the right wingers having the
guns and they are increasingly seeking firearms
themselves and obtaining them almost like
a race to the bottom of sorts, if you will.
Do you do you sympathize with that fear?
Does that does that make sense to you?
To some degree.
Speaker 5: Well, I mean, the Supreme Court,
of course, in Heller versus District of Columbia,
said that the core of the individual right
under the Second Amendment is the right of
self-defense in your home.
And people have that right.
That's deeply anchored in American culture
and law.
And so if there are people who are fearful
for that reason and they feel that firearms
will keep them safe, you know, they have a
right to exercise their Second Amendment rights
in that way.
Of course, the liberals in the Supreme Court
had advanced the traditional view, which is
that the Second Amendment is about the right
to possess guns in connection with militia
service.
In other words, you read the prefatory clause
without a regulated militia being necessary
to the survival of the free state comma in
conjunction with the operative clause, the
right of the people to keep and bear arms
so that in any event, that the conservative
majority won on that.
But even Justice Scalia was emphatic that
reasonable gun regulation is totally within
the contemplation of the Second Amendment,
and you're going to have to sell assault weapons
to anybody, and you don't have to allow kids
to get weapons and you don't have to allow
people to take weapons into public places.
You know, I hope we have not arrived at civil
war style conditions, but I you know, I think
it's perfectly healthy for people across the
political spectrum to exercise their Second
Amendment rights.
But it's also perfectly healthy for us to
understand what Second Amendment rights really
are right, and what the authority is to guarantee
public safety, because that's essential to
the social contract.
And the whole reason we get into a social
contract, if you read Locke and Hobbs and
Rousseau, is that we sort of surrendered the
rights of violent self-help in exchange for
security in a civil society.
But the Republicans who refused to do nothing
essentially, you know, give us the worst of
both worlds.
They compel kids to go to school under the
truancy laws, under the mandatory attendance
laws, but then they leave them as sitting
ducks because they won't do anything to keep
them safe from mass slaughter with assault
weapons.
Speaker 1: Congressman, last thing I want
to ask you about, and I know our time is not
unlimited.
I am not an advocate of a primary challenge
to Joe Biden.
I think if Joe Biden decides to run for reelection,
that he should be the Democratic nominee from
a strategic point of view.
That being said, when people say to me, David,
is there anyone you think would be interesting
to see as the Democratic nominee?
To be totally honest, I think of you I think
of Jon Ossoff.
I think Jon Ossoff would be very interesting.
I know that it would be a crazy thing to ask
you if it's something you're think about thinking
about.
You would never answer it.
It would be inappropriate.
It would be a crazy thing to ask.
But my more specific question is, one of the
things I do think is I think that unfortunately,
because of anti-Semitism on both the right
and some on the left, I think Jewish presidential
candidates would still struggle because of
anti-Semitism.
What's your opinion about that issue in America
right now?
Speaker 5: Huh?
I hadn't really thought that through, David.
Well, let me see.
And I wonder if you're asking me this, because
I happen to be in New Hampshire campaigning
for my friends Chris Pappas and Annie Kuster
and for Senator Maggie Hassan.
But, you know, look, I think it's really important
for the young people of America to understand
and the kids of America to understand, despite
what they might see on the Internet and despite
what they might hear from some people in public
office.
We are not a racist country.
We are not an anti-Semitic country.
We are not a sexist, misogynistic country.
We are not an immigrant bashing country.
And I believe so much in, you know, what Tom
Paine saw when he got to America.
I mean, he said this country could become
an asylum for humanity, not an insane asylum,
mind you, but it could become a place of refuge
for people fleeing from every form of political,
religious, economic repression and discrimination
on Earth.
And I think despite what we've lived with
through Donald Trump and the Proud Boys and
the Oath Keepers and the militia groups and
the three percenters, and despite all of the
divisiveness and the polarization, I still
believe we are the world's greatest multiracial,
multi-religious, multi ethnic, constitutional
democracy.
And the sky's the limit for what we can make
happen for our people once we fight off all
of these authoritarian, racist attacks on
our country.
So, you know, there there would be a lot of
reasons that I wouldn't run for president,
but being Jewish would not be one of them.
Speaker 1: Congressman Jamie Raskin, I really
appreciate your time.
And we're going to be watching next week as
the hearings start very closely.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 5: Thanks so much for having me, David